Devils Tower is an amazingly special
place it's just up and out of the
prairie like what happened here
[Music]
there's something inexplicable but
happily undeniable about the power of
devil stone I'm Frank Sanders then I am
a professional rock climbing guide not
sure how I got here but the shoe really
fits I've been climbing since I was
fifteen so I guess I've been climbing 50
years 65 years old still doing it first
time I saw The Devil's Tower up real and
close was June of 1972 and that night
the sky was full of lightning flashes
the booms illuminated the tower
I was intimidating sure that's why I
came all that way to be intimidated
I have somewhere around 2,000 a sense of
the tower the joy in guiding is to be
along when somebody else hits that
experience and you get to share it
that's fantastic
The Rock wants to be climbed and if you
look at the rock the rock will show you
right where to touch and how hard to
touch right on Vardhan the tower is a
ever-ready
partner I don't want to sound too trippy
here but you touch it it touches you
[Music]
getting to the top of the towers both
the physical and an emotional spiritual
journey looks like I can't do it but
then in your heart you believe you can
be on top to be honest with you for me
it is a letdown we've run out of rock to
climb right now Devil's town if I had to
pick one word is home for me
[Music]